今僕普通に自然にしてるように見えるんですけど実は講義でめちゃくちゃ苦しい聖魔実
は
wave さんの4名
本当かお前はいんだけどいやねぇいいねぇ鼻をかむ動作したりちょっと舌下もあったり
すると
コメッツいたりする
御算用ちょっとしてみてもいいですか
ございます
スワップ
ブーブーこれ
ん
迎える第0同横断的でいたんですよね金はちょっと夜中なんですけども
ちょっと寝れなそうなんで明日ももうすぐお仕事入っていかなきゃいけないんで
ちょっと夜中に救急で病院に行ってちょっと見てもらおうと思います
久しぶりに病院に行ってみようと思いますではレッツラゴー
ちょっと新小結とかすると痛いですね
はいありがとうございます
3つします
[音楽]
さっきあの2人入って破砕いたんですけど結構痛いんですよまずは動画撮ってる場合
じゃないと思うかもしれないんですけど
緊急の時の病院に行き方と忘れないと多いでしょ一応ちょっと見とき近所の近くの音
救急病院を調べてそこに電話してください
ちょっと向かいます
[音楽]
あれなんかもうこっちのが張ってるぐらいの95するの
入ってあげる病院に着きました早速救急に入ってちょっと見てもらいましたといえば
入っています
[音楽]
いや
したいスネア
これだと思いたいんです実あの痛いですこんなにたいのかっていうねちょっと見たくて
ですね
ですいませんちょっとあの原因については分かりませんでなんか全然分からなかったん
ですけども急に動画編集してたらなんか夕方ぐらいに痛くなってきて皆さんのご存知か
わかんないんですけど僕ここ12年間病院一回は行ってないんですよ
そんななんか不死身の男がですね満を持して救急です
深夜に病院行くってもうその行動通りあのめちゃくちゃ痛くて何だろ席とか吸ったり鼻
かなリストが三井たかったんですけどまだ耐え得るなーと思ったんですけどもくしゃみ
したときもうこれじゃないなと思ってそれで病院に行ってレントゲンと ct 検査
撮ってもらって結果
[音楽]
ばっちこりひびが入ったということでございますいやめずら政治は僕が救急で病院運ば
れることですはないんで
じゃあここにてしっかりとバンドを巻いてます痛み止めもちゃんともらってきました
はいもうちょっとゲーに関しては心当たりがあるようなないような
分からない人は最近なんかめちゃくちゃ花管理しててたわけわかんないもん
ばっかり食べてなんか骨が弱った可能性もありますそれで何か朝に俺からではないかな
と思うんですけども
うんうーんこんなにた稲わらにひび割れのって全然太陽と思えば買えるんですけども
痛いか痛くないかというとめちゃくちゃ痛いんですよ
救急で病院行ってなんかさっきも動画を撮ったんですけどもねのページに出さだ
いいかなと思ってる正直対し
たことねぇなんと思って出さないようにしてるんですけども年間
日が経つごとに痛みがどんどん増してって僕より呼吸するだけで痛い状態になってると
今ここへ来俺だけじゃないよね
俺だけだったら俺なんか別の何かかと思っちゃうよこれやばいマジでびっくりさ長打
だけで痛いです真似したら痛いんだろう
例えばこのこの動画でいた椅子横がちょっと動くだけでも一体でもの広い
[音楽]
ああ
会いたいなぁあんまりもの入ってないユップ目土あげるだけでも結構痛いんで応援を
持つとマジで痛いです
痛いし
ああ
ああああああ
席もできないです遊ばれたのが言いたいんですよね皆さん僕を殺すのは今です
笑わせてください肋骨が折れで米ヒビ入る方が立場でみたいなこと聞いてこっちのは
治りが遅いみたいで多分3週間以上かかるみたいなことを言われました
q 気鋭の病院行った後にまた後日数あまりにだすぎて生活に支障が出そうだったんで
もう1回風に行ったんですけどまぁが
ここど骨って現状をどうすることも出来なくてもうバンド巻いて痛み止め飲んで湿布と
か貼って早く治すのただたら苦痛とともに待つしかないらしいです
そんなことあるああああっあの声としたくないんですごめんと言いたいけどいやあの
やばいは本当に痛いんですよ肋骨笑うのを見たいんですけど一番痛いのはくしゃみなん
ですよねぜひともみなさんに見せてあげたいですねが肋骨て機構折れやすいらしい人生
は俺当たりませんで申す皆さんが折れた時にあくしゃみしたらどれだけ痛いんだろう
なっていうのは僕の今から実際見せるんでそれ
ねあー怖いなっていうのをぜひ知ってくださいで特に痛いなかなかね陽気な時ですね寝
たり起きたりの動作の時にめっちゃ負担が盛んですよね
[音楽]
いやだ骨は位とって臭みで骨をれるらしいですからね
b r
[音楽]
う
ちょっとちょっとしばらく安静にしますでかい声も実は出せなくて叫んだねしてもに
対し
ハ中でも痛いですよ
できる子づらい安房今と思いたいですけどもしですね僕ととか出会うことがあったら
あのぜひ笑わせてみてください
すごい痛がると思うんで
ファーザーん
男性に自分
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ